so endet dieser film abrupt und
unerwartet
als ich diesen september zusammen mit
hygiene auf die reise ging wussten wir
nicht wohin diese führen würde
im nachhinein aber ist mir klar ich habe
sowohl richtung als auch tempo dieser
fahrt falsch eingeschätzt
das ist das klassische tablette das mit
mir noch der beschauliche über wäre mir
eine ehre auf stumpf wurde bestätigt und
sich bis jetzt gibt es das sind sie im
land zog sich zum färben auch die
sharing zu nehmen
danke die t city im kampf gegen krebs
selber bestimmt wann frieden ist
davon handelt diese geschichte
[Musik]
ja das tut sie sie haben sogar was haben
jetzt vier millionen wähler im kreis
sitzen immer glaube ich wollte nicht
aber das will ich zuständig dafür ist
der wirtschaftsführer dividiert die zahl
das ist schon so ja ja das ist aber der
mann ich habe millionen war abkaufte der
letzten sieben sind nicht sagen das bin
ich bin verhalten da bin ich eher
weniger schön ist natürlich super sagt
rudolf gruber wusterhausen für ihre
alten jungen
seit februar dieses jahres ist dies ja
nie an magenkrebs erkrankt trotz
todesurteil erkämpft dies ist bereits
die dritte strahlentherapie in folge
verblüffend offen so hat sich der alt
ständerat von jeher gezeigt krebs hin
oder her aber ein tabu gibt es dann doch
seinen von der krankheit ausgemergelten
körper den zeigt er uns nur bedeckt 15
mit der klima weniger durch ist kriegt
das ist äußerlich der zerfall ihnen
wuchert die ursache der krebs der 62
jährige hofft diesen seinen widersacher
mittels strahlentherapie zu stoppen
aber nachdem bereits wer glaubt die sie
habe diesen kampf früh aufgegeben wird
eine magenoperation 24 bestrahlungen und
sieben chemotherapien hat er bereits
hinter sich
es ist der griff nach dem rettenden
strohhalm nach dem leben
trotz ärztlichen fertigt darunter zu
mehren
und das war nicht den weg weist
[Musik]
dank stetig es runter gar nicht recht da
also nicht auch unter sie jetzt aber
dass entlang kommt das gar nicht recht
einstellen
sie wissen das ist ja so abo oder
richtig worden die kanzler bruch
kathrein
vibrant scene achterbahn hat mir
persönlich hat es gewaltig viel mit
relativ gut
das problem soll gemacht mir langsam ins
gewicht
einige meistern haben was man so macht
das immer besser und dann ist der frau
gemacht und ich heute eine der woche mit
essen und man keine ziel und sehr wie
den stoff sehr motiviert und es geht
einfach nicht dennoch wird man zum
beispiel als möglichkeit würde mutter
morgens unterwegs
das wird heißt es ja noch die hochzeit
tragen sie im anschluss konnte sich aber
doch flüssig nicht künstlich normal
ernähren
das heißt sie sind frei reden aber dann
aber über geworden richtig
dass diese wollen in der hauptsaison
verletzte verstehen
er der so vieles bewegte und bewirkte
für ihn reduziert sich nun das
wesentliche auf die nahrungsaufnahme
[Musik]
ursula abgottspon seit vier jahren die
frau an seiner seite muss mit ansehen
wie ihr tipps woche für woche schwindet
das gefühl ich jetzt sehe nicht schlecht
ja und ich gewinne mit mit hoch oder
situation ein hauch von hoffnung es
schien als habe der plan dieser reise
sich geändert raus aus dem tunnel licht
und perspektive ein stück geschenktes
leben nach diesem düsteren tragen der
niedergeschlagenheit
[Musik]
auf seiten der mit denen die irgendwo
seine frau dagegen erlebte noch eine
höhere ordnung auszeit dann keine mehr
kombinieren der nationalversammlung
glaubt ich komm praktischen versuche
schlussmann schlimmste kreisstadt
bleiben dann dauert haben brauchen
wieder richtig euphorisch links hier
unter sich noch als jeder ist ein
richtig zählt noch der ruf ich kannte
ich bin ich da bin ich krank aber ein
modell ist gewarnt meinte für mich also
tor ist man in mehreren ist das kalt
dafür die absicht nichts nach
die familie hündin wacht vor dem eingang
von jannis baufirma ton rtt ag
drinnen treffen wir den chefs am
schreibtisch an der hong kong bereits
mit für der orders und jetzt mehr
braucht auch die haarpracht zu sehen
sind natürlich willkommen
der hessische gibt auch gutes leben mit
einer berlin
oben auf dem gipfel angekommen als
beliebter und geschätzter politiker und
millionenschwere bauunternehmer er der
tief unten angefangen hatte aufgewachsen
im sozialen elend verwahrlost von den
eltern im stich gelassen
so habe die drei mit einem musiker
taktet und das ist schon noch dass ich
dann schon rechnet christian sievers im
juni angehobene ziel haben wir der
stromzähler korrekt oder kritisch und
dem ec maxi sind irgendwelche schlecht
zum feldsee als ich mutter als ich die
op schwester ist die geschichte durch
meine wenigkeit deutlich cousine und ein
cd ältere gezeigt einnehmen obwohl noch
motor dann fiel etwa nach erholung und
mir der politisch viel gepäck machte ich
noch relativ beschlagen semikontakt aber
haben mit zeit kontakt wodurch ohne
kinder ohne grab nicht untätig waren
bezirke ist normal war
[Applaus]
so lange es geht weiter machen so lautet
seine devise
tochter jenny wäre nicht er hätte er die
zeit nach seinem tod nicht sofort und
sauber geregelt
der rücktritt als ständerat ist bereits
vollzogen mandate niedergelegt die
firmenleitung dem sohn übertragen
selbst für hündin luna ist vorgesorgt
sie wird ihren platz bei ex frau heidi
finden
der erhalt der firma ist gesichert
unmittelbar nach der schock diagnose hat
der unternehmer seine mitarbeitenden
informiert
die nacht hat man natürlich nicht
schlafe ich denke die wirtschaft bald
ist ja diese haben ist schwer
vorstellbar dass ich auch als problem
hat natürlich seine bewegte jetzt noch
das 2 2
hier auf diesen saftig grünen fleckchen
erde hoch über glarus ist die site und
25 jahren daheim
während wir seine lebenspartnerin filmen
wird sich der 62 jährige kurz aus ein
bild welches man vor der krebserkrankung
höchst selten sah die szene lernte die
dreifache mutter an einer
delegiertenversammlung der svp kennen
was als zufällige begegnung begann wurde
zur zweiten chance auf eine große liebe
vier glückliche jahre dann kam der krieg
[Musik]
zwischen der schmerz sei dass ich im
schlaf so verwandelt sich schon seine
fühler sind von 20 mannschaften finden
er ist kein mann der kitschigen gesten
für ein kuschel bild auf der couch ist
er nicht zu haben
[Gelächter]
lieber zeigt er sich so mit helm auf
gewohnten
baustellenbesuch zusammen mit sohn
matthias dieser tritt in die fußstapfen
des vaters der übrigens auch wirklich
ein vater war trotz einen termin konnte
[Applaus]
ich andere situation trotzdem sich wahl
und hilflos dem schicksal ausliefern ist
nichts für macher ja nie er hat
vorgesorgt wie notfalls den begleiteten
freitod wählen
da muss ich mir jetzt bevor ich sprach
mit den eckwerten noch keines ist fühlte
sich unter druck
zu diesem zeitpunkt aber schon der tod
noch in weiter ferne
wir planen voraus die nächsten aufnahmen
in der politiker nicht um 20 der 120 den
beiden weil sie eben auch für die
sandige reporter noch hat es da mit
einer einigung kommt hat sie die cd
aufnahmen oder und damit natürlich dass
ich mit mit aufbauen wenn die zahlungen
doch dann der bruch des juni liegt im
spital glarus der krebs hat unerwartet
und mit voller wucht zurück geschlagen
noch einmal macht es ja nie ein thema
vergeblich mittlerweile wird er
künstlich ernährt die entscheidung zu
gehen steht fest ein interview wollte er
keines mehr geben stattdessen so war es
in seinem sinne redet seine partnerin
für ihn hätte es ja im spital
wenn ich weiß ich noch nichts gehört
aber nun im spital ich weiß es gibt
einfach nimmer gehört ja
das geht nicht mit kampf und krampf es
geht jetzt nicht mehr machen ich will
kein festival hat er ist gegangen wie
erlebte entschieden und selbstbestimmt
neben den angehörigen und mitarbeitenden
nehmen auch politische weggefährten
abschied
christoph mörgeli war zusammen mit
hennes familie bis zum schluss bei ihm
das ist natürlich offen und wird der
hammer gespürt da sein entscheid fällt
hat und weil man sie die konsequenzen es
auch haben küsst sie handgreiflich wird
mit der kunst schöne und lustige zeiten
mit genannt verbraucht dann gehört
natürlich dazu kameras sind unerwünscht
die von christoph mörgeli verlesene
trauerrede
wen wundert's hat es ihm nie selber
verfasst
[Musik]
teenies familie wusste von diesem film
ex frau heidi und die gemeinsamen kinder
haben sich wie all die jahre zuvor
lieber im hintergrund gehalten gemeinsam
mit lebenspartnerin ursula begleiteten
sieht es in den tod
[Musik]
eigentlich und jetzt ist knüppeldick und
ich bin froh wieder da die krux ist mit
dem schluss die familie und ich dass mir
das zimmer in sohail begleitet man nach
der einigung im streit
[Musik]
eine woche nach der beerdigung ursula
abgesprungen ist wieder zu hause in
zermatt
allein die wochen zuvor hatte sie ahnt
ist jenes seite im spital verbracht
im wissen dass er bald sterben wird oder
deutlich bezirke was sie ihrem erinnert
er ist die sache wo 30 sie tut man das
will ich mal sagen ein ganz schön ruhig
geblieben aber mitschuldig so dass auch
hier natürlich dürfen nur einige oder
dass man gehört von einem handgerät aber
speziell etwas machen jetzt ein richtig
sie wachsen
die zweite das verlieren aber das sind
artikel oder wenn oder wie ein
fingerabdruck oder marko hildmann von
passiv
ja und nein
[Musik]
diese reise hat ihr ende genommen
ja hier ist schluss disney ist wenn man
so will vorzeitig ausgestiegen
über den moment des abschiednehmens
hatten wir zuvor miteinander gesprochen
[Musik]